foreign
hello sir let me ask you a few questions
definitely yeah yeah I'm actually I'm
super glad you guys are here right now
are you smelling that weed smell yeah
because a dude broke in smoked weed and
bolted
do you think it's the same dude that
left that bong there on the floor
yes
hello hello what's your name my name how
do you like it no
like that
I imagine you're holding coffee
this is outrageous where are the armed
men who come in to take the protesters
away where are they this kind of
behavior is never tolerating in baraqua
you shout like that they put you in jail
right away
no trial no no nothing journalists we
have a special jail for journalists
you're stealing right to jail you're
playing music too loud right to jail
right away you're driving too fast yeah
slow jail you're charging too high
prices for sweaters
glasses you write to jail you undercook
fish Believe It or Not jail you overcook
chicken also Jam under cocoa can you
spell that please m l
he
d
Clay did you say clay yes the clay is
silent all right got it have you seen
this man before he was shot last night
oh thank you no sir that's ours we need
that we handy kept it
now I know your gentleman had a long
flight but I have prepared a welcome
party in your honor excellent I like to
party well my job is to see to your
every need
do we just uh select the woman we desire
and we'll take the large black one
interesting choice what did you have
some kind of a book with photos of the
women available to us if not I will also
take the sexy black one
I am not surprised at all I've been to
South America I did very well there
NYPD
this is oh boy NYPD syrup have you seen
anything unusual today oh no
this was nice thank you wait
what is this music
oh this is from my country near
krakengovia do you like it I weirdly do
[Applause]
foreign
fun thing about working cases you meet
people from all over the world
this song is a celebration song from
when a dog loses his virginity look who
checks that I think there might have
been a translation problem when I said
party I meant one that did not include
sex for pay
but one that had food and drink and
dancing that sort of thing
so no women
no we have so much to learn from each
other
how many birds do you guys eat chickens
us too amazing
what is this water
I'm sorry agua in our country government
officials drink only bottled water well
I can assure you that that water is very
safe to drink
no bottle please send the boy
Tom go get water
Leslie come on for your troubles
you got a chief
this is a gold-plated replica of the gun
Oco Chavez used in the 1992 socialist
Revolution it is a gift
this gun truly symbolizes the blossoming
piece between our two Nations
[Applause]
we two are pleased to be here in your
dirty alleyway
we thank you for the container of sap
I mean bag of garbage it's funny because
Antonio said to me can we turn this car
around and
say we're sick or something or that we
lost our way of course that would be
rude to you
hey I know you you're believnos no
we have never met no I'm pretty sure we
have you send me horse blood no would
you like to buy horse blood no you know
maybe we don't need music for this
that's totally fine we can just skip
that part of it
[Music]
molypnos plays like an angel
where it go
hey millip news I don't know you
okay
the banana you wanted Senor finally
what
with your hands
to peel the banana
hey what's
up I would like to see where the
children are fed the sweeteners
a restaurant American children are
fighting more efficiently than any other
children in the world I mean
they're like little basketballs I mean
they're huge you know workers okay this
is our thermometer
I'm trying to turn a giant dirt pit into
a community park but I need 35 000 and
the city doesn't have enough money in
its budget
I do not understand you've never had a
budget shortage no
Venezuela is blessed with massive oil
reserves massive I mean tremendous like
do not believe the state sells the oil
and keeps all the money and
we build whatever we want
wow well
now I do not understand
I feel like my English was very clear
should I repeat Venezuela Venezuela my
country
has a lot of oil oil is food for cars
hello
hello is there anyone here
leibnose no
yeah you played violin in my wedding
your belief nose no my name is Jerry
Barbara
it doesn't matter I need your help can
you please hand me the keys that are
down there
thank you I love Keys oh and this is for
you
as they say in my country right
and what country is that again Honolulu
Okay
okay you know if it's all the same I'd
really just rather have the key here I
don't want the key perfect
thank you malipnos no it's jetty
foreign
the first time
everybody doing okay back there
comfortable
well the motel we're putting you up in
is really nice
you can watch TBS
do you have tbs in Venezuela
I have everything in Venezuela
and four satellite dishes in my estate
okay
14 000 channels
fourteen thousand
I already know who wins Project Runway
wow I'm coming over to your house then I
see what you're getting at but no thank
you I'm still primarily interested in a
large black woman
um
the parks in baraco are far superior
they Park in my hometown El parque Del
Este we have a monorail and we have an
aquarium and we have the haripa
amphitheater is huge Lady Gaga played
there last week great well we don't have
Lady Gaga
and I don't think she's going to come
here unless her career takes a very bad
turn
but we have something more beautiful
than Lady Gaga
democracy you make an appointment with
the dentist and you don't show up
Believe It or Not jail right away we
have the best patients in the world
because of jail
all right